tributes around the city are piling ever
higher as grief sets in New Zealanders
are finding ways to express their sorrow
over a massacre in their Muslim
community for now it's still a crime
scene but police are picking up flowers
to take closer to Al Noor mosque where
dozens of people were slaughtered during
their Friday prayers
on the other side of the park Christians
weep and pray for their fallen Muslim
neighbors one woman has brought an art
project meant to show the bond between
the two groups so this is an out work
that I did for today for some Patrick's
Day and I wanted to make something for
the whole community to acknowledge his
sadness and sorrow and a feeling of
connection with the Muslim community
this man has found another way to show
his support I've had quite a few people
come and have coffees and hugs it's been
nice I guess it's nice to see people
just showing up in showing the support
in solidarity which is I think what New
Zealand is all about being welcoming and
loving and peaceful people the support
for the victims is overwhelming most
here are satisfied with the government's
response to the murders but they want to
know how the suspect slipped through the
cracks
they say more needs to be done to
address racism and to help individuals
who think the world is against them we
can't help the people who already feel
like that but we can at least try and
stop the younger ones from replicating
less if we can
the message here is clear that hate has
no place in New Zealand
GWS Claire Richardson with that report
and she joins us now from Christchurch
where she's been tracking that story now
Claire I understand Prime Minister
Jacinda R Dern has been meeting with
members of New Zealand's Muslim
community that's right she was here in
Christchurch meeting both of ICH terms
and leading members of the Muslim
community she then went on to the
capital Wellington where she has been a
meeting Muslims there as well and she is
doing everything she can to put this
community's mind at ease firstly she has
offered continuing police protection for
their mosques so that they can continue
to pray at their places of worship
without fear she has also made clear
that these individuals affected are
eligible for a ten thousand dollar grant
to cover the cost of funerals and said
that immigration status will not be a
factor in whether or not people can
receive them she said there will be
additional funding to help these people
down the road available as well now the
one thing that many people in the Muslim
community are very upset about here is
the question of what to do with their
dead in the Muslim faith it's very
important that bodies are buried as
quickly as possible but certainly within
24 hours
and obviously that mark has long passed
so a lot of people are particularly
distressed over this issue we're also
starting to learn more now about how the
moments before those attacks played out
what can you tell us about that that's
right the police confirmed today that
from the moment they received an
emergency call until the time armed
officers arrived on the scene was just
about six minutes and a little over half
an hour later they were able to
apprehend the key suspect there's
footage of a police vehicle ramming his
car off the road and they were then able
to take him into custody and now the
people I've talked to here are generally
very happy with both the police response
and how the government has reacted to
this tragedy
obviously it has been a day of mourning
but overall when you talk to people
about how the response has been handled
people are generally satisfied with that
response
the Prime Minister has also announced
plans now to tighten New Zealand's gun
laws of how much support is there for
that move that's right just the day
after the shooting the Prime Minister
promised that she would at tighten gun
laws she's also said that she will meet
with her cabinet tomorrow and they will
be having preliminary policy discussions
on issues including what to do in terms
of gun legislation now many people were
very upset to learn that the suspect in
these attacks was in legal possession of
five firearms we know that he used a
modified semi-automatic weapon or is
alleged to have used one in the attack
and that he was able to purchase these
after acquiring a license a standard New
Zealand license back in 2017 so people
are asking how a man like this was able
to possess such weapons and speaking to
people here there is a lot of support
for the idea of making sure that that
grade of weapon cannot fall into just
anyone's hands alright D w's Claire
Richardson there for us in Christchurch
New Zealand thank you very much